Du kan høre min performance.
While you're doing it, just think out loud what you're thinking while you're doing it.
Let's do it again.
You can talk while you're watching.
I didn't go as extreme as I wanted because the mats were a little bit slippery and unstable
because of my weight and the setup was small, but I think overall the movements I executed
were not bad, but definitely improvable.
But some movements...
I think the kicks I did today were okay and the quality execution was better than I expected.
The video looked better than what I felt when I did it.
Overall it was a positive and I like the routine I executed and the movements I did were good
to my standards.
See you next time.